how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel where we talk
about Marvel and all things relating to
the MCU today we got some venom 2 news
including a leaked first look at the
carnage symbiote the actual carnage
symbiote and not just Cletus Kasady who
we've seen several leaked photos for so
far and based off of these leaked photos
that we've gotten for carnage it looks
like fans are not going to be
disappointed with how he's going to look
in the film we also have some venom 2
trailer updates today that we'll talk
about in this video when to expect it
even with the pandemic going on right
now so I hope everyone is staying safe
be sure to subscribe with notifications
turned on so you don't miss any of the
Marvel videos while you're in quarantine
so the last time we left Eddie Brock and
the Venom symbiote they were talking to
Cletus Kasady who of course in the
comics and in the movie will go on to
inherit the carnage symbiote there was a
nice little teaser for carnage in that
scene where Woody Harrelson's character
Cletus says when I get out there will be
carnage but let's talk about where
exactly he's located in this scene
because it's very important to the film
he is in the Ravencroft Institute in the
comics Cletus is being held in the
Ravencroft Institute he inherits the
carnage symbiote and carnage helps him
escape he escapes with Francis Louise
Barisan who is shriek and shriek has
already been confirmed to be in venom 2
and is looking like we're going to have
a very similar story happen in the movie
if we take a look at this very first
leaked carnage symbiote photo we can
tell that it's behind a cage a cage that
looks very similar to the one that
Cletus Kasady was behind in the end of
venom 2 so it's looking like it could be
just like maximum carnage where the
carnage symbiote helps Cletus Kasady
break out of the Ravencroft Institute
now there have been a few supposedly
Koto's of the carnage symbiote but this
is the first seemingly real one that
we've gotten and it looks like it
answers the question that we've had for
a pretty long time of whether or not
carnage is actually going to bond with
Cletus Kasady while he's in the asylum
and help him break out in the movie but
if we take a look at this photo it does
look like the symbiote has already
bonded with Cletus Kasady if you noticed
in the first a venom film when de
symbiotes were on their own and not
attached to a human host they are kind
of just a blob they don't really have
much shape or form until they bond to a
host once they bond to the host
get their classic symbiotes form as we
can see in this photo it definitely
looks like it's already bonded to Cletus
and it looks like this is its hand and
luckily it's sticking true to the comic
accurate version of carnage we can see
the razor-sharp claws that it has and of
course the symbiote can morph into
whatever it really wants to take the
form of but in the comics carnage does
have those razor-sharp claws so it's
nice to see that we are going to get a
somewhat comic accurate version of
carnage now you may have seen another
leaked photo of the carnage symbiote and
unfortunately a lot of people do believe
that this is fake there is always the
possibility that it could be real but
the general consensus is that it's fake
now Sony seems to have a very similar
marketing plan for the trailers of their
films right before the Morbius trailer
came out we got a leaked photo of
Morbius walking down an alley and in the
background there was a picture of
spider-man on the wall that said
murderer over it this was definitely
something done intentionally by Sony to
get the hype up for the trailer because
it was coming out in just a few days and
the fact that we are getting this leaked
photo of carnage means that the venom 2
trailer isn't that far away
the first venom had an October first
release date and venom 2 has an October
2nd release date the first teaser
trailer that we got for venom was
February 8th and then the first official
trailer for the movie was April 23rd so
we're well past the point of where we
should have already received a teaser
trailer for venom 2 now of course the
virus has affected a lot of studios and
a lot of studios are working remotely
now but again the fact that we've
received this photo of carnage means
that the trailer is most likely going to
be happening very soon but let me know
what you think about this first
real leaked photo of the carnage
symbiote even though it's just an arm
and a hand do you like how it looks
let me know what you think in the
comments down below don't forget to give
the video a like and subscribe and
notifications turned on so you can enter
my giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
one or a ps4 I'm picking a winner at
five hundred and fifty thousand
subscribers as always thank you all so
much for watching we'll forth